ja schön wenn morgen meine damen und
herren also heute wird hier abgestimmt
vier vorschläge liegen auf dem tisch der
bundeskanzler wermes gehört wollte ja
eine impfpflicht auf jeden fall er kann
sich aber nicht durchsetzen in seiner
eigenen koalition das liegt vor allen
dingen an der fdp deswegen hat er das
ganze in die fraktionen beordert
gruppenübergreifend hat man gearbeitet
und nun liegen also vier vorschläge auf
dem tisch die opposition hält sich nicht
so richtig an diese vorgabe denn die afd
liegt einen eigenen antrag vor komplett
geschlossen und darin fordert sie das
ende aller maßnahmen auch die
impfpflicht für gruppen die schon seit
dem 15 märz gelten in krankenhäusern und
pflegeheimen die werden sollen
aufgehoben werden es gibt einen
vorschlag der cdu csu auch die besteht
auf einen eigenen eigenen fraktions
vorschlag da geht es um ein impf
register und stufen pläne die dann im
herbst scharf geschaltet werden können
und bei der fdp da hatte man sich ein
bisschen aufgefächert wolfgang kubicki
und ungefähr 50 mitstreiter da sind
leute dabei viele aus von den linken
aber auch zwei cdu abgeordnete viele
fdp-abgeordnete also die fordern keine
impfpflicht aber vermehrtes werben für
eine impfpflicht sie sind anders als die
afg der meinung dass das sehr gut ist
sich persönlich impfen zu lassen das
aber der staat das nicht befehlen sollte
und befehlen kann und dann gab es eine
gruppe um den fdp gesundheitsminister
ullmann die haben gesagt wir müssen die
menschen erstmal ordentlich beraten und
wenn das alles nichts nützt müssen wir
dann im herbst eine impfung vornehmen ab
50 jahren diese gruppe hat sich jetzt
der stärksten gruppe angeschlossen diese
gruppe von herrn kuhlmann hatte ungefähr
45 mitglieder und die stärkste gruppe
237 mitglieder das ist die gruppe die
von vielen ampel politikern forciert
wurde eine impfpflicht für alle ab 18
jahren diese gruppe ist jetzt den
anderen entgegengekommen hat gesagt auch
wir sind für einen impf register
einloggen von der cdu/csu ist das
natürlich und sie hat gesagt wir
vereinigen uns jetzt mit der gruppe von
herrn ullmann und werden eine
impfpflicht ab 60 einführen vorher
müssen alle beraten werden und es gibt
eine möglichkeit im juni da noch
auszusteigen wenn es gut voran geht und
im herbst beraten wir dann nochmal ob
die 18 jährigen und älter sich auch
genügend geimpft haben oder ob man da
nicht doch eine impfpflicht für alle
einführen kann also eine komplizierte
ausgangslage
es geht nicht nur um sachfragen sondern
auch um taktische fragen und ich will
darüber diskutieren mit meinen beiden
gästen dirk wiese und sepp müller bei
der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende ihre parteien spd
und cdu/csu spielt aber keine rolle
heute den ich hab's ja gesagt
fraktionsübergreifend herr wiese sie
also stehen für diesen antrag
impfen für alle sie haben das jetzt
modifiziert impfen ab 60 unter anderem
ja auch ein im register muss eingeführt
werden es soll eine beratung stattfinden
wer soll das machen wir haben uns erst
mal als stärkste gruppe in der
verantwortung gesehen am wochenende auf
die anderen zuzugehen um ihr heute im
deutschen bundestag eine entscheidung
herbeizuführen die die bürgerinnen und
bürger auch zu recht erwarten nach sehr
langen diskussionen in den vergangenen
wochen und ich will das noch mal
herausstellen wir wollen eine
impfpflicht letztendlich auf 60 weil wir
wollen für den herbst vorsorge treffen
wir wollen dass diese pandemie
beherrschbar wird wir wollen nicht
wieder über freiheitseinschränkende
maßnahmen im kommenden herbst bei einer
möglichen neuen welle diskutieren
sondern wir wollen vor die welle von wir
wollen vorsorge treffen das eint uns
letztendlich darum haben wir diesen
kompromiss den ich für richtig halte auf
den weg gebracht auch mit einem schritt
auf die union zu im hinblick auf das im
register und wir werben heute hier
letztendlich für die mehrheit und ich
halte das auch für richtig heute zu
einer entscheidung zu kommen herr müller
die union legte einen eigenen antrag vor
dass im vorsorge gesetzt was ist daran
besser als an dem vorschlag den herrn
wie sie vertritt ja uns eint das ziel
dass herr vorsorge betreiben vom herbst
und deswegen ist es richtig dass die
ampelkoalition er jetzt unser gutes
thema das im register übernommen haben
aber sie machen zwei unterschiede wir
wollen weiterhin auf freiwillige
beratung setzen hier möchte die ampel
eine beratungspflicht und die ampel wird
jetzt eine impfpflicht für ab 60 jährige
allen führen das halten wir nicht für
verhältnismäßig weil wir gar nicht
wissen welche variante im herbst auf uns
zukommt und deswegen möchten wir einen
regelmäßigen bericht des
bundesgesundheitsministers im deutschen
bundestag und nicht über markus lanz
beraten sehen damit wir darüber
entscheiden können ob es notwendig ist
eine impfpflicht stufenweise einzuführen
ab herbst sie fordern eine
beratungspflicht was eigentlich auch
logisch ist wenn man sieht dass der
kanzler gesagt hat bis februar sind 80
prozent geimpft hat nicht geklappt wir
sind bei einer quote von 76 prozent
warum ist das in deutschland so schwer
und b wiederhole ich meine frage von
vorhin wer soll denn beraten ich glaube
die beratungspflicht ist wichtig sie
vorzuschalten um nochmal aufzuklären die
bürgerinnen und bürger die noch nicht
geimpft sind auch über vielleicht
falschinformationen noch aufzuklären was
über die ärzteschaft die apotheken
letztendlich angegliedert sein soll was
jetzt beginnen soll wenn das zum erfolg
wird sagen wir ja auch ganz klar muss
man überlegen ob man das dann überhaupt
scharf schalten soll das halte ich auch
für absolut richtig aber hier ist noch
sehr viel luft nach oben ich gebe ihnen
das beispiel des bundeslandes bremen wo
wir fast eine impfquote von über 90
prozent der bevölkerung haben wo viele
sehr gute beratungsleistungen erbracht
worden ist in bayern und sachsen ist das
anders gelaufen dort haben wir
schwierige impfquoten in der derzeitigen
situation die uns große sorgen für den
herbst bereiten also von daher nochmal
wir haben hier einen sehr guten
vorschlag aus meiner sicht vorgelegt es
ist ein kompromiss der unterschiedliche
gruppen vereint der aber auch die klare
unterstützung der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat denn
ich will noch mal daran erinnern dass
sich alle ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten der bundesländer
auch für eine allgemeine impfpflicht
ausgesprochen haben auch die der cdu csu
die das noch mal bekräftigt haben vor
ein paar wochen und von daher sehen wir
auch dass die unionsfraktion sich hier
auch gegen ihre eigenen
ministerpräsidenten heute stellt herr
müller ein schwieriges problem bei ihrem
antrag finde ich dass sie im herbst
reagieren wollen die auf die situation
angemessen das ist insofern verständlich
als dass der impfstoff den wir jetzt
haben ja so richtig gegen unikum gar
nicht funktioniert und sie wollen gucken
welche virus dann david aber ist das
nicht ein problem wenn sie dann erst
anfangen ältere menschen zum beispiel zu
impfen das dauert ja eh die dann
sozusagen ein schutz haben ist das nicht
zu spät was sie vorschlagen danke für
die frage das lässt auch die möglichkeit
zu klarzustellen dass mit der
erstimpfung die überlastung des
gesundheitssystems entgegengewirkt wird
das sagen nicht nur wir sondern
wissenschaftler mit studien und karl
lauterbach hat da von anfang januar
zitiert die erstimpfung hilft watson
tage später gegen eine tödlichen verlauf
mit dem corona virus und sie sprechen
jetzt richtiger weise an die impfungen
gegen das corona virus jetzt mit dem
jetzigen impfstoff ist noch nicht sicher
war ob die gegen die impfung gegen das
virus wird welches dann im herbst bietet
ja das ist ja die enttäuschung von
vielen die gebucht sind und reihenweise
krank werden dass das nicht so
funktioniert wie man sich das als laie
vorstellt ich dass mich impfen dann bin
ich safe vielleicht bin ich dann nicht
ganz so krank dass rk ii hat jetzt eine
untersuchung dass über 60-jährige 0,2
prozent der gebucht hatten einander auf
der intensivstation der nicht geimpften
das sind ein prozent zu riesig groß ist
der unterschied zumindest bei nikon im
moment nicht man muss aber eins noch mal
deutlich klarstellen und das ist auch
etwas was ich gerade in vielen
zuschriften als frage bekomme die
impfung ist nicht hin sozusagen schützt
nicht vor einer sterilen immunität sie
können sich noch infizieren aber die
impfung schutz nachweis nicht davor dass
sie einen schweren verlauf einer
infektion haben und das muss man immer
noch mal hervorheben die impfung schützt
vor allem schweren verlauf nachweis
nicht das können wir auch ganz klar
belegen an den studien die wir haben und
das ist ja letztendlich auch das ziel
was wir haben die schweren verläufe
kommen in die krankenhäusern sie
belasten das gesundheitssystem und darum
ist ja die vorsorge vor dem herbst
gerade bei der gruppe der über
60-jährigen so wichtig weil dort
nachweislich die meisten schweren
verläufe sind und es ist nicht so dass
eine impfung bereits ausreichend ist sie
brauchen mindestens zwei impfungen für
eine grundimmunisierung besser noch den
schutz durch die musterung und darum ist
der vorschlag den mechanismus den die
union vorschlägt viel zu spät und vor
die welle zu kommen das was die union
vorschlägt wird wieder dazu führen dass
der freiheits einschränkungen im herbst
haben dass wir geschäftsschließungen
haben auswirkungen auf die schulen haben
und das ist aus meiner sicht keine
vorsorge herr müller haben sie
verständnis für bürger die sagen der
staat kann mir dass sich anweisen ich
will nicht geimpft werden weil der
gesetzgeber das ist der gleiche
gesetzgeber der in dieser woche eine
riesen kapriole geschlagen hat sie habe
gerade die ministerpräsidenten
angesprochen die gesundheitsminister
haben gemeinschaftlich beschlossen mit
dem bundesgesundheitsminister dass alle
maßnahmen abzuschaffen sind und dass
eben ein erkrankter auch nicht mehr in
quarantäne gehen muss wir haben das alle
mitgekriegt der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat das dann
anderthalb tage später oder nacht
zurückgeholt dieser gleiche gesetzgeber
der sagt also das sind zu viele
einschränkungen
das nehme jetzt mal alles schön zurück
gegen jeden menschenverstand dieser
gesetzgeber sagt dann aber im herbst auf
jeden fall ihr müsst geimpft werden
damit ihr auch geschützt sei das ist
doch schon zufrieden das durcheinander
was sie ansprechen hat karl lauterbach
und der bundeskanzler zu verantworten
die menschen draußen verstehen diese
pandemie politik zu recht nicht mehr und
wenn sie jetzt den gesetzesentwurf sich
anschauen dann sieht der gesetzesentwurf
eine immunisierung ab drei spritzen vor
das wäre der nachweis gleichzeitig wirbt
karl lauterbach für über 60 jährige mit
vier spritzen die stiko empfiehlt für
über 70-jährige die vierte spritze also
da passt wissenschaft und kommunikation
in die breite öffentlichkeit nicht
zusammen und deswegen wird das ziel auch
nicht erreicht was die amtliche erzielen
möchte eine höhere impfbereitschaft zu
erreichen weil die menschen einfach
durcheinander sind wo ich die ampel
politik in der pandemie wie sie ist es
nicht auch verfassungsrechtlich ein
problem also in griechenland gibt es
diese impfpflicht über 60 in italien
eine impfpflicht über 50 und die
österreicher als graf hatte gebracht
eine impfpflicht zu verabschieden und
mussten die gleich wieder aussetzen weil
sie nämlich gesagt haben dass omikron
virus ist mit so einem harmlosen verlauf
für die meisten menschen verbunden dass
dieser grundrechtseingriff einfach nicht
akzeptabel ist warum wollen wir uns so
was auslasten wir halten das was wir
vorgelegt haben für verfassungsrechtlich
zulässig es verfolgt ein legitimes ziel
der mit dem schutz vor einer überlastung
des gesundheitssystems und darum auch
den schutz von uns fielen die geplante
operationen verschieben müssen die nicht
stattfinden können und darum ist es ein
verfassungs legitimes ziel das wir damit
verfolgen das ist geeignet erforderlich
es auch verhältnismäßig das hat uns die
anhörung die wir im deutschen bundestag
gehabt haben und man eindeutig bestätigt
und ist es ja auch so dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht auch die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht in
einer entscheidung noch einmal bestätigt
hat die wir auf den weg gebracht haben
also von daher verfassungsrechtlich ist
das was wir auf den weg bringen zu
lassen jetzt kommen wir ein bisschen zum
politischen raufen herr müller
ist das was die union der macht mit
einem eigenen brief an die abgeordneten
der empfiehlt also wenn ihr antrag nicht
angenommen wird dann bitte keinen
anderen antrag zustimmen nicht eindeutig
darauf gerichtet den kanzler einen
auszuwischen ihm ganz klar zu zeigen
ohne die union in deiner ampel hast du
keine mehrheit für gesetze und so ziel
dass es unseren guten antrag
durchzubringen dafür werden wir auch
heute werden dafür liefen auch in den
letzten tagen die telefone heiß wir
haben versucht mit der gruppe um
entriegeln und jörg wieso auch ein
kompromiss zu finden der vorgelegt ist
kein kompromiss mit unserer gruppe und
dann ist es folgerichtig dass natürlich
die fraktion mit ihren abgeordneten noch
mal für unseren antrag wirbt bei dieser
ist zielgerichtet dieser wird uns vor
der herbst welle schützen wenn wir den
umsätzen sind wir gut gewappnet für die
dinge die im herbst auf uns zukommen
sollten muss ich noch mal sagt
nachsitzen im prinzip ist ja auch die
union oder die meisten in der union sind
für eine impfpflicht im herbst nur in
der lage angepasst wenn jetzt ihr antrag
nicht angenommen wird dann wäre es doch
folgerichtig dass viele sagen gar nichts
kommt stimme ich dem antrag der
mehrheitsgruppe zu ja gar nichts kommt
das sehen wir bei der sektoralen
impfpflicht wie teilweise schlecht der
die regierung diese umgesetzt hat und
deswegen ist unser werben auch für unser
gesetz wir hätten uns gerne noch ein
wenig zeit genommen um es auch gemeinsam
mit der ampel auf dem weg zu bringen
damit wir die feinheiten wer also alles
umsetzen auch ausgestalten können sie
hören ja die kritik der gesetzlichen
krankenversicherung sie hören die kritik
der kommunen an dem gesetzesentwurf von
der krise karl lauterbach und olaf
scholz dieses nicht umsetzbar herr wiese
ich hab so ein bisschen das gefühl bei
ihnen ging es die letzten vier tage
darum egal was hauptsache impfpflicht
sie haben zwei mal modifiziert sie haben
auch einen free geste eingebaut um der
union entgegen zu kommen und christian
doerr immer in der fraktionschef der fdp
die eigentlich im ullmann antrag
nahestand hat gesagt ich kann bei dem
anderen nicht mitmachen und der hat es
auch angedeutet ich übersetze dass mal
was sie davor liegen ist ja letzten
endes doch immer noch der versuch eine
impfpflicht für alle im herbst
durchzusetzen denn das ist ja dieser
zwei stufen plan erst ab 60 und wenn das
die beratung nicht funktioniert dann
eben ab für alle nein mit diesem
kompromiss übernehmen wir verantwortung
weil wir glauben das ist wichtig vor die
welle im herbst zu kommen damit wir
nicht nochmal und das sage ich sehr
deutlich nicht wieder
freiheitseinschränkung im herbst haben
das möchte niemand und darum ist es
wichtig vor die welle zu kommen
frühzeitig vorzusorgen und das machen
wir mit unseren kompromissvorschlag den
ich für richtig halte aber ich muss
schon sagen auch wir waren gestern im
laufe des tages erstaunt dass friedrich
merz sozusagen den abgeordneten der
cdu/csu in einer ethischen medizinischen
debatte sozusagen fesseln angelegt hat
dass er ihm klar vorgibt wie sie
abzustimmen haben das ist schon ein sehr
merkwürdiges demokratieverständnis des
fraktions position der cdu und zwei
halten sie sich zumindest zwei halten
sich nicht daran die sind bei wolfgang
kubickis antrag aber davon mal abgesehen
hand aufs herz die
unions-ministerpräsidenten werben für
eine werbung die fraktion tut das quasi
zumindest für den mehr als antrag hier
nicht passt das zusammen ja unsere
ministerpräsidenten sind natürlich im
steten austausch ich habe auch gestern
noch mal mit einigen telefoniert und sie
finden unseren antrag richtig weil er
uns gut vorbereitet und vor allem auch
gemeinsam mit der ampel müssten wir uns
auf den weg machen die impfzentren
weiter zu finanzieren weil wo wollen sie
ihr angedachte beratungspflicht den
umsätzen die ampel möchte die
impfzentren ab mitte diesen jahres nicht
mehr zu finanzieren das ist schizophren
das ist das falsche signal
und da muss die ampel jetzt arbeiten das
wollten wir mit einbringen für gespräche
war dann keiner mehr bereit herr müller
herr wiese vielen dank für das interview
danke